we have in gq
just a delightfully absurd profile of
aoc uh who they're trying to set up to
be a future presidential candidate here
here are just some highlights from it
people ask me questions about the future
and realistically i can't even tell you
if i'm going to be alive in september
and that weighs very heavily on me and
it's not just the right wing misogyny
transcends political ideology left right
center this grip of patriarchy affects
all of us not just women men as i
mentioned but also ideologically there's
an extraordinary lack of self-awareness
in so many places and that that might be
the truest thing she's ever said there
is an extraordinary lack of
self-awareness i'm pleased to report
what day is it it's september 8th we are
now more than a week into september uh
aoc has survived she is alive good i'm
glad i'm glad you could make it aoc
later on in the profile gq asks her
outright do you think that you can be
president and and
the
fear that aoc has the little hesitation
that she has to be president is the
scariest thing of all